قساوه على الجدران ان ضاقت او رحبت هذا كل
ما تحتمي به العائلات هنا كسوه للشتاء
عرضت اجسادهم تلجا العائله الى هذه الحيله
سخونه تنقذ ما خلفته الليالي البارده في
كابول هنا في الشتاء على مصرعيه لا شيء
يقف امامه زائر انهك الصغار
البروده هذا الطفل يعاني من الامراض ايضا
انه يعاني من شتاء قاسم حقا وليس لديه
جوارب ولا احذيه ارتدائها
منازل بلا اسقف نزحت اليها مئات الاسر
الافغانيه هربا من حركه طالبا اسقطهم مر
اللجوء في بلادهم الى ان استقبلوا الشتاء
الاصعب منذ اعوام شرد وقت المئات حتى الان
مع تساقط الثلوج وهطول الامطار ولا احد
يساعد الاهالي يعانون من الامراض ويموتون
بسبب البرد القارس
شاهدتم راماتت بسبب شده البرد ولم يكن
لدينا المال الكافي لشراء نعش لها
خلال اسبوع واحد توفي ما يقارب 80 افغانيا
بسبب الشتاء القارس وفقا اخر احصائيات
رسميه ضحايا البرد مرشحون للازدياد مع
استمرار انخفاض درجات الحراره نهلك عن
اوضاع اقتصاديه طالت اساسيات الحياه غذاء
السالم العربيه